les bruits ambiants dans une ville comme
montréal peuvent être une source
sérieuse d'un confort et même entraîner
des problèmes de santé chez les
résidents pour en atténuer l'impact des
chercheurs ont analysé le phénomène en
temps normal mais aussi durant
confinement ce qu'ils ont découvert va
vous surprendre
[Musique]
quartier des spectacles juillet 2019
catherine coste aveeno et son équipe
prennent des mesures de niveau sonore
pendant le festival juste pour rire à
montréal début juin 2020 la chercheuse
est à nouveau à l'oeuvre mais cette fois
l'ambiance sonore est tout autre on en
confinement c'était vraiment un peu trop
calme pour le centre-ville
on avait l'impression d'être dans une
ville fantôme un peu complètement
déserté
catherine costa bino et chercheuse au
psy kohaku stick
depuis 2003 elle arpente des quartiers
de montréal
armé d'un sonomètre d'enregistreurs elle
mesure les niveaux de bruit identifient
leurs sources
puis questionne les résidents comme les
passants
son but rendre la ville plus agréable
d'un point de vue sonore
ans
[Musique]
encerclés de thermopompes et
climatiseurs de véhicules en tout genre
de chantier de construction de drones
avions qui volent au dessus de leur tête
les citadins sont envahis par le bruit
les conséquences vont d'appels de
sommeil à l'infarctus en passant par les
difficultés d'apprentissage à l'école
l'ambition mondiale de la santé
considère que le fardeau du bruit en
termes de santé est équivalent à celui
du tabagisme passif en quartier des
spectacles
catherine guastavino travaille avec la
ville limiter les impacts du bruit sur
le voisinage
depuis que la place des festivals a été
inaugurée au centre ville il y a plus de
dix ans les immeubles résidentiels se
sont multipliés dans le quartier avant
la pandémie
les enquêtes ont montré que les voisins
et des surtout contrarié par le bruit
après les concerts finalement les gens
n'étaient pas congénères
par les festivals mais mais plus par la
gestion de la foule après une fois que
le concert est terminée là on se
retrouve avec des milliers de personnes
qui vont rejoindre le métro ou marcher
dans les ruelles en juin 2020 la ville
immergés timidement d'un premier
confinement l'absence de foule et le
ralentissement de la circulation
laissait entendre de nouveau pris dans
le quartier comme celui des systèmes de
ventilation des grandes tours les bruits
des travaux de construction avaient
repris à un niveau égal parce que la
plupart des raisons préféré entendre
concert de la musique de cet acte d'orly
[Musique]
les cannes et qui sont en train de
vagues
[Musique]
catherine costa finaux et son collègue
promet du moulin ont modélisé la
propagation du bruit autour de la place
des festivals le modèle tient compte des
différentes sources sonores mais aussi
de la disposition et du revêtement des
bâtiments qui réfléchissent leçon à la
place des festivals la majorité des
bâtiments sont très réfléchissants les
seuls matériaux les surfaces qui vont
être absorbante ça va être les carrés de
pelouse par exemple donc c'est carré là
on va les identifier et on va leur
donner une propriété d'absorption et là
on va avoir une idée de quel va être le
bruit qui va être ressenti par un
résident on pourrait imaginer par des
calculs prévoir quel va être le bruit
dans son logement ça c'est en prenant en
compte l'isolation la façade
leurs travaux ont permis de modifier
l'orientation de certaines scènes
ils ont permis de choisir des haut
parleurs plus directif pour concentrer
l'énergie acoustique vers les
spectateurs et réduire la propagation
vers les voisins
ailleurs dans la ville les problèmes de
bruit sont plus difficiles à gérer
donc une fois qu'on a construit par
exemple si une garderie au bord de
l'autoroute ya pas vraiment de solution
miracle et c'est les solutions qu'on va
vous préconisez dans ces moments là sont
des solutions comme des murs antibruit
qui sont très coûteux installé à
maintenir la chercheuse crois qu'on ne
sait pas suffisamment contre lui dans
l'aménagement des villes souvent il ya
des préoccupations visuel qui vont
prendre le dessus par exemple si on
pense aux règlements domanys à montréal
pour tous qui équipements mécaniques
donc le terme aux conques les unités de
ventilation de climatisation
ça doit pas être visibles de la rue donc
du coup on se retrouve souvent avec ses
équipements à l'arrière dans les ruelles
vertes et qui peuvent être très bruyant
donc là on a un décalage entre un
environnement visuel qui va être très
vert très très intimiste très calme et
des équipements très bouillant qui vont
se retrouver dans ce même environnement
catherine coste aveeno milite pour que
la dimension sonore trouve sa juste
place dans les plans d'urbanisme au même
titre qu'on produit des plans et des
images de synthèse pour imaginer à quoi
pourrait ressembler une future place
publique où un immeuble résidentiel
on pourrait simuler son environnement
sonore tel moment de sa conception
je rajoute sur le bon mot riels du
trafic dans son laboratoire de
l'université mcgill
l'équipe arrive à reproduire des
ambiances sonores pour trois dimensions
peut rajouter alors ça c'est souvent pas
perçue comme très agréable
une climatisation assez forte
[Musique]
pour le projet place publique prévue à
l'angle des rues mont-royal une mentana
sur le plateau mont royal
l'équipe a fait venir des volontaires en
laboratoire pour tester différentes
ambiances sonores
[Musique]
étonnamment un niveau sonore plus élevés
étaient parfois jugée plus agréable par
les participants tout dépend de la
source
on peut rajouter une fontaine au milieu
et parce que ça donne on peut imaginer
rajouter un piano en libre service dans
la rue
à droite cette fois ci le confinement a
donné un nouvel élan pour recherche de
catherine guastavino dans plusieurs
quartiers
les résidents se sont réappropriés leur
jardin grâce au ralentissement de la
circulation
dans le quartier des spectacles le
niveau sonore a baissé jusqu'à 10
décibels pendant la journée
cela revient à diviser le niveau de
bruit par dix mais assez vite
concerto à des situations les gens nous
disaient qu'ils étaient trop calme c'est
un silence parce oxygène pour un
centre-ville de ne pas avoir cette
activité humaine
comme quoi le silence n'est pas toujours
la solution
l'objectif devrait pas être uniquement
de réduire le niveau sonore mme et
assuré qu on a un environnement de
qualité
[Musique]